the Joe Rogan experience I do not think
polyamorous folks are on the right track
I think that what they're up to is I
mean I know from the ones who are
serious about it and talked about it
that even within the polyamorous
community there's a recognition about
just how difficult it is to make it work
but I don't really want to interfere
with their right to do it I would like
to be able to talk about whether it's a
good idea whether it has societal
implications that we should be aware of
but body you feel like they're not on
the right track and isn't everyone's
track I mean if we can accept trans folk
and we can accept women to subscribe to
cultural norms and wearing high heels
and makeup in the worst place why can't
we accept polyamorous behavior and what
so that's what I'm telling you is
difficult though I personally would
counsel somebody if you know and I have
had this conversation with many students
for example I would counsel them away
from it because I think it actually
prioritizes one thing which is desirable
but that the cost of it is very very
high
what is it prioritize it prioritizes not
locking yourself into a single sexual
relationship and I think there's a way
in which there is a terror that
surrounds locking yourself into a single
sexual relationship and part of the
terror goes back to what we were talking
about at the beginning of the
conversation if you think that beauty
max is maxed out at 20 and then it wanes
over life then as a woman you're trapped
in this terrible situation where you've
got this power long before you know what
to do with it and it's going to
evaporate so you better capitalize that
and if you're a man you're very
frightened that you're gonna get into a
relationship and then you're gonna watch
this person that you love fall apart in
front of your eyes and you're gonna be
you know you're gonna be caught in that
situation and I don't think this is the
reality of a pair bond I think the
reality of a pair bond is way better
than we fear but that because we've got
this overly simplistic mythology
surrounding it a lot of people are
trying to solve that problem how
why not get locked into that
relationship that's going to trap me
with somebody who's how do I not get
bored and decaying in front of me right
yeah I don't think it's a decaying thing
I would push back against that I would
say people just want more variety they
just want they're attracted to other
people they want to act on that and if
they find a partner who was also willing
to do that and they stay together I
don't see what would be the issue if
they wanted to do it well I'm I'm
telling you specifically that I don't
want to stop them from doing it but I do
want people to think very carefully
about the issues I mean I'm just
speaking as one guy who's lived one life
the value that I get out of having as
close to perfect security at home as I
can have in a relationship I mean
Heather and I have been all over the
world we've taken our kids in to parts
of the Amazon that are four hours by
boat from the nearest road right this is
not a boring relationship this
relationship has been a non-stop
adventure right but no one's trying to
push polyamory on you right well a I
wouldn't say that that's true I would
say that the bar not as an individual
but what I would say is they are
promoting an idea that this is the
sophisticated way to live it's the wave
of the future if they yeah and that a
common is this is this well I mean you
mentioned sex at dawn yourself and so
the idea is yeah but Chris is my friend
and he's crazy there you go
but what I would say believes it he
might be right he does believe it and I
you know I'm it is right I have been
convinced by a friend you know who I had
a long-standing argument with on this
topic and what he convinced me is that a
friend who is polyamorous yes a friend
who is polyamorous and this friend has
convinced me that it can be accomplished
that there's some work to get but he
acknowledges that it actually in the
case that he points to took several
generations literally several
generations to arrive at a stable
situation well you guys have a wonderful
relationship though I know many people
who have terrible terrible relationships
and for
the notion of monogamy seems absurd it
seems like a trap you get stuck in you
grow to resent each other and then you
get sick of each other and then you
fight in court until you figure out who
gets all the money so I would say you
know those people shouldn't be together
I think you're right yeah but then
there's a conflation between polyamory
and promiscuity right that just a
free-for-all a sex with strangers
free-for-all is different from the kind
of careful approach to polyamory that
this friend takes which still looks
extraordinarily difficult to pull off
given what human beings are from a
jealousy respect that isn't monogamy
extraordinary difficult to pull off
meaning isn't the rate of divorce in
this country alone it's somewhere around
50% and Chris Rock famously said that's
just 50% who had the courage to leave
how many cowards still but here that
this is this is part of the point about
novelty we are living in a situation
where our narratives sell us a false
picture of our opportunities our
narratives are partially driven by an
economy that wants us to be insecure
enough to spend money like crazy and so
I'm not telling people that they should
live one way or the other
I'm telling them that they should
understand what their real options are
and polyamory as an experiment is all
well and good but what happens when you
introduce children into the mix right
that's very very different it's very
different because children are so costly
to raise and because human males are
wired to fear raising offspring that
they themselves did not produce
genetically now I don't think it makes
sense to actually care very much about
your genes and advancing their interests
I think this is something evolution has
stuck us with that is not valuable it's
actually destructive potentially move
past but we are wired for it and so what
I'm expecting to happen is if you have a
large-scale experiment in polyamory what
it's going to do is it is going to break
down
into polygyny and it is going to break
down into single motherhood as men leave
these relationships in order to engage
in perhaps more polyamory with younger
women and it's going to be yet one more
thing that is unevenly distributed
between the sexes so choose your mate
wisely well choose your mate wisely but
we don't even realize that we are
interfering with your ability to do that
in ways that we don't we don't into it
we have a landscape in which nobody is
paying attention to the way we are
interfering in the normal processes that
would cause you to find a mate with whom
you might have a very rewarding what
lifelong process is are you referring to
well let me take an absurd one okay we
have no idea what effect deodorant is
having on us
choosing the right mate we do know that
there are studies that there are
molecules that you can't consciously
tell you're detecting that do effect
mate choice and we know that we're
interfering with that stuff well we know
that birth control affects that as well
as well
yeah specifically woman's ability to
smell whether or not she's even
genetically compatible with the man
absolutely and which is really freaky
it's like those lizards how do they know
right well no rubbing up against each
other sense so I think I think what do
you wear deodorant I try not to at the
moment I'm wearing it because sweat
stains would be socially oh you're
wearing anti purse I guess I am yeah
distinction there yes dangerous well but
here this logging up your pores this is
a great this is a great example because
I actually did spend I don't know if was
a year as an experiment not wearing
deodorant how'd that go well he was
already married so a couple interesting
facts one it did drive some people crazy
I'm sure um not me though not you didn't
drive you didn't bother you at all I'm
gonna we've all been around people we
love who at some point we're like dude
take a shower right but yeah yeah no but
as long as you took a shower
shave the armpits thing like if you
shave your armpits dude I mean see it's
the one spot right we're not putting
deodorant anywhere else on our body
we're just putting it on the armpits
like is it the shaving thing I'll give
you shave your armpits if you shave your
armpits you decrease the radius Kelly
diffuses you know the environment so
should make a judgment call well but in
some sense look I don't know which it is
maybe we're being wusses right and we're
being you know we've got an industry of
I don't know how much they make per year
selling us these things because we're
afraid of our own human smell right
right but there's a huge difference
between the way somebody smells if they
don't have good hygiene and somebody who
has the luxury of daily showers and
doesn't wear shirt frankly I don't find
somebody who is taking daily showers and
isn't wearing dude I don't find it that
off-putting and in Europe it's
considered just a different smell you
smell them as opposed to smelling right
guard or whatever this exactly and so
anyway I have no idea whether if we
backed our deodorant and antiperspirant
stuff off whether it would change who
ended up with whom and whether or not
marriages might have a small degree of
change right but how many other things
are there on the list that we wouldn't
think to name what about makeup
what if women stopped wearing makeup how
much would that change who hooks up with
who how much would it and you know if we
how much would it change if we actually
learned that there's a difference
between hotness and beauty and we
actually allowed little girls to
recognize that maybe they weren't so
interested in being hot because although
it gets you a lot of attention it's the
kind of attention that's a dead end
right how much would that change who
ends up with whom I mean a lot of who
ends up with whom at the moment is
presumably dictated by people having had
their attention captured through hotness
and then there's a question of whether
there's anything there to back it out so
I what I want to see for my own kids
sake is I want to see a world in which
the noise of the way the market
influences how we interact with each
and the notions that get promoted as
sophisticated where that noise is
reduced so that people can really begin
to detect the patterns in their life
actually this worked for me I dated in
this way and this worked for me I dated
in that way and it didn't work for me it
wasn't rewarding that begins to tell you
something
[Applause]